du vert partout et sur tous les tons
vous l'avez reconnu c'est le python
d'enchin une légendaire montagne qui
domine l'Ilette àidote au cœur du cirque
de Salazie il faut environ 1 heure et
dem de grimpette pour accéder à son
sommet tout plat
mais pourquoi l'appelle-ton le python
d'chin est-ce que vous savez qui était
enchin non je sais
rien Mar du tout sa femme se serait
suicidé jeté dans le vide P un esclave
pas trop qui est parti avec sa femme
enceinte qui a ACC couché sur le python
tué par par les chasseurs d'esclav c'est
un esclave quand Mme célèbre
ici
du haut de ces 1350 m d'altitude le
python d'enchin porte encore fièrement
la légende des Vailles en chin celle de
deux esclaves malgaches parti maronné
parce qu'ils étaient maltraités par leur
maître au début du 18e siècle le couple
s'évade malgré les svices encourus le
Code noir de 1723 prévoit en effet qu'on
coupe les oreilles des fuyards et qu'on
les marque au fer de la plantation de
bois rouge de Monsieur de font orbière
il fuit dans le cirque de Salazie
longeant la rivière du M sur le python
il trouve un bon refuge à l'accès
difficile d'ici il sera aisé de
surveiller les alentours enchin
construit une case au plus haut du
sommet un véritable nid d'aigle il sème
les graines et le riz qu'il a emporté
dans sa fuite dans le cours d'eau il
ramasse le Cisson il pêche aussi dans la
Mar à poule d'eau en 25 ans la famille
s'agrandit de H enfants et survit grâce
à la terre enchin réussit une une fois a
échappé à Bronchard le chasseur d'esclav
marron employé par son maître mais la
fin de la légende varie d'une version à
l'autre trahi par la fumée d'un feu Eva
et Anchin auraient été finalement arrêté
et ramené à la plantation certains
affirment qu'anchin aurait été tué lors
de sa capture d'autres qu'il se seraiit
jeté dans le vide et transformé en
Papang il reste en tout cas un symbole
de
liberté
c'est
où